my childhood is the first two words that
come into mind when i was one of those
nerd kids in the 80s who who spent their
kind of all their time in a darkened
bedroom hacking away on games
jetpack there was my misspent youth
playing jetpack over i can't remember
summer 84
85 something like that
probably c5
the beauty of them was that you could
you could understand the entire computer
the operating system the basic language
that was built in and
and so on
the best time i ever had as a computer
scientist was when i was programming the
spectrum age 16 or 17.
loading screens
failed
loading turning tapes over
banging them or something like that
this video is brought to you by the
letter z and x and the number 81.
[Music]
i'm just collecting a few memories of
people who've been on computer file
who've memories of sinclair and the one
thing i thought you could perhaps bring
to the table is is a bit of a memory of
the man himself because we've talked
about his machines before you and i on
computer file what was clive like i have
to say probably before we even start i'm
probably a little bit of a fraud on that
school because a lot of my memories have
survived of other people's memories
right i've spoken to enough people that
i you know i feel i know the guy well
but i you know i met him once and and so
so from my point of view my personal
memories um is the guy was an absolute
gentleman you know and he was
engaging
um he was interested in what we were
doing then there's interviews that i've
done with
a lot of people that have either worked
for him or worked with him and that sort
of thing and there's two sides of the
coin as there always is you know um and
the biggest question i get is about
micro men you know was he really like
he's portrayed in micro men for viewers
who perhaps aren't aware of this maybe
viewers in the states this is a tv movie
which may or may not be available on
youtube i shall not uh um
if you were to search for my chromebook
you may come across it
you look back at the the 1980s or the
late 1970s we're at a time where
computers were quite scary right there
were these big expensive things um and
so clive sinclair came in and
broke through made the first big mass
market mass appeal cheap computers that
people are able to program and create
their own things on started with the
zx80 in 1980 a year later created the
zx81 and then the year after that
created the famous zx spectrum as well
which is kind of the cornerstone for a
lot of the the british kind of uk
software and video game development
industry well i changed my life
completely i'm sure many many people are
going to say the same thing i mean i
wouldn't be a computer scientist and
sitting here today in a computer science
department if it wasn't for clive
sinclair so as many people
started about the age of 14 one of my
friends got a zx81 and i was very
envious and we spent all our spare time
at his house typing in games from
magazines and in those days the
magazines come out every week
and they had machine code games and in
hexadecimal which you had to type in
very very carefully if you made one
single mistake everything crashed and
you had to start from scratch so we got
very good at typing in these games
and that's kind of what we what got me
started in uh in the sinclair machines
in the media they sort of made out
almost there's an element of
making them out to almost be a joke in
in some forms
the little zx80 with this white
case and and the
extra memory pack you had to put on the
back and how it would always
wobble and you needed to cool it down
with a pint and milk tetrapakka milk
and the little plastic keys it's
actually fantastic design i mean so
absolutely
ingenious is one word which comes to my
mind that
it was actually an incredibly skillful
piece of engineering and an
incredibly creative piece of engineering
i started off with the zx81
loved it and then graduated the zx
spectrum and i have a vivid memory the
zx spectrum bringing it home plugging it
into the tv putting the cassette in and
it making it
noises and then in color color up comes
a rainbow on the screen line by line
it's got how we've entered the 21st
century now it was just amazing you have
uh a starring role in micro men the film
yeah
yeah no no i don't have a starring role
i i
played a silly bit part um and looked
like a muppet but we did do all the
computers for it and supplied the tech
and and advised on various aspects from
a technical point of view
as did clive actually and as many other
people when people find out that we were
involved with it um it is a film that's
gone down really well with everybody it
seems to to have anyway um and and it's
great that we played our part in it but
a big question we get is you know was
was the club really
you know like he was in the film because
he was extremely shouty and sweary and
um you know
was he really like that uh and the
answer
that i can best
judge from the conversations that i've
had
um is absolutely he was um you know
however however um the film is at a time
when he had his back against the wall
you know he was um uh trying to get the
contract for the the bbc computer um and
he didn't get it and things were um
not going well for him and in those
situations yes um he was like that um
and in fact various people have said he
was underplayed on that front you know
um it sometimes wasn't suitable for tv
we got a zx 81 for christmas not this
one this one i picked up off someone a
few years ago it still works apart from
a few keys on the keyboard but we got a
zx81 at home and then about nine months
after that we upgraded to a zx spectrum
as did my granddad he got one as well so
sinclair computers were around all the
time as i was growing up until i
graduated to the atari st and things the
british video game industry would not
look like how it looks today without the
efforts of clive sinclair and you know
the zx spectrum dma design based up in
dundee started as a
zx spectrum coding club right and then
they eventually went and made lemmings
and developed a certain game called
grand theft auto that obviously has been
been taken now and it's grown to this
huge kind of uh behemoth um but also
loads of loads of video game studios
started off programming on things like
the zx spectrum um and the z structure
made possible um
ultimate play the game which you now
know as rare started creating games for
the zx spectrum but also obviously the
commodore 64 as well um and because the
zx spectrum was so cheap and was so mass
market it allowed anybody really um to
just get in and start making their own
things so you know it definitely forms
the foundations of what we know as the
british games industry you literally
have to say okay i can move like little
sprites around the screen and i'm only
going to be able to have like eight or
so sprites on the screen what game could
i come up with which like will you use
that you had to design the games around
the technical ability of the computer so
you had to look at what it could do and
how it would work and how much memory
and then design your game according to
it whereas as computer technologies got
better you design your game first and
the computer has to fit it it's cheap so
if you look at the price of the
spectrum computers i mean they're
ridiculously cheap uh for the time i
mean i
i was looking as recently and working
out how much to be how much they'd cost
nowadays and it was you know like 200
300 quid or something like that which is
amazingly low low price especially for
something that's
uh
you know at the forefront effectively of
home computing at the time eventually
after much pestering i managed to
persuade my parents to buy me a sinclair
spectrum and i think i had a paper run
for about two years to help fund that as
well and that's when i really started
getting into the programming side of
things with the sinclair machines and
what got me really hooked and this is my
oldest book programming the z80 by
rodney zacks and the z80 processor is
what powered all the sinclair machines
and i learned z82 machine code about the
age of 16 or 17 and i started
programming my own games and that's what
really got me hooked on on computer
science and that's how i became a
computer science professor in the end he
was a very very clever guy let's not
forget that he was um you know a member
of mensah and he chaired mensah for many
years right so um he was a very clever
guy and if you didn't have the skills uh
to be able to talk on his level then he
could quite easily
become
uh a bit shouty you know but just very
very dismissive
however
uh on the other side of the coin um i
know people work with him said he was
incredibly generous um with um he you
know in in many ways one with kind of
things like christmas um uh presence uh
for staff fortner and mason hampers when
things were going well for for all the
staff regardless of the level uh that
they played in the company um uh huge
parties you know kind of um well can
only be described as um
you know
glitterati kind of parties and that and
they and they had people there from all
walks of life um
and they were extravagant and they were
fantastic and people really enjoyed them
um so much so that a lot of people can't
remember them uh
you know so
he was very very generous and he was a
really nice guy even somebody that cuts
his grasp for him you know would be
given a sinclair spectrum yeah here's
this for the kids you know enjoy it sort
of thing this is one of the games uh
which i wrote um 37 years ago when i was
16 and it's a game called hyper ball
which actually sold managed to get this
running on an emulator a few years ago
so this is my youngest son tom and this
is him playing the game i think he was
about 12 at the time so it's a little
shoot em up game it's not very not very
fancy game um but yeah when i when i
look back at this i'm quite surprised
that a 16 year old could write something
like that this is one of the nice things
about the sinclair machines even as a
kid you could understand absolutely
everything about them and actually for
me that the main challenge was doing the
graphics we used to get bits of graph
paper and just color color the squares
in to make the little characters and
that was
writing the program wasn't very
difficult for me but doing the graphics
and making it look good um was was the
difficult part obviously there were
faults with it i i did i had a z8 a z8
zx80 the original white one with the
original 1k memory
and then as i earned a bit more money i
got the memory for the i've got the
money for the uh for the 16k expansion
pack and you stuck it on the back
and it would if it became a bit wobbly
and then it would it would break and the
computer would go down because you'd
lost your extra 16k of ram
and then you could say you could find
that you could tilt it and put a weight
on it to get the connections were better
i didn't have a color monitor so i had
to go into one of the shops in one of
the computer shops in my hometown of
glasgow and play my games on the color
monitors to make sure the the graphics
were all right and then
tweet the graphics and then take them
home and then sell the games a friend of
mine had a zx spectrum
i myself i had already a patch 2001
which was 6502 based yeah so i wasn't so
much involved at this point i was so
much involved with
z80 or
sinclair or anything
but i i i did program that 80
and that was when i worked in my first
job for company
next of microprocessor engineering uh
and there i i did lots of z80 assembly
programming so i i know i know
so a9 is load accumulator to memory i
know still some of the opcodes it was
fun i mean it had what's called a mouse
piano where every bit you could set
and everything was in hex so it was real
you had your fingers on on on the real
machine at the time it was real
real uh computing and not this fake
stuff we don't know this we had a um
a spectrum 128k plus 2
which had a built-in tape recorder
what kind of springs to mind is just
hearing the sound of
binary essentially data that turns into
an audio signal it's just such a
distinctive thing
that's what a lot of people talk about
when they when they remember the
spectrum and another sort of
machines of that time that era
i think that's a kind of it's a really
really striking striking thing to be
able to hear the sound of digital
information i had a zx81 that was my
second computer
um
i didn't
i didn't particularly want it but i
could actually i'd ordered um
a bbc micro and
the but the waiting lists were like i
know six months or something when it
first came out so
um
in the end i
fairly briefly had a
secondhand zx zx81 just to sort of tied
me over till the bbc was delivered the
zx81 i was kind of you know very small
quite sort of plasticky with the the
weird sort of film keyboard every key
did about five or six different things
so you'd end up doing this a vulcan mine
grip to type in the character you wanted
the website has every item that we have
in the collection listed on it all the
sinclair products of a computing nature
anyway that people can go and have a
look at this information about clyde
there's a timeline for his products and
their history and things like that so
yeah it's all on the website so it gets
ridiculed because it had a number of
drawbacks uh and deficiencies but
nothing else touched it on price okay
this was the first machine you could
really go out to the high street and buy
from somebody like boots or w.a smiths
and that was a big deal so is no longer
looking in the back of the electronics
magazines this was walking down the high
street oh look there's a home computer
should we buy one um and people did and
they bought a lot of them i mean
actually in the sort of early 80s 82 83
84 you could walk into wh smith's which
was a news agents in the uk and you'd go
upstairs or to the back of the thing and
they would have
as zx spectrums on stale they'd have
oryx they'd have bbc micros they'd have
commodore 64s
and things on sale they would sell them
they would sell the games for them the
hardware the accessories from them and
so you'd walk in there but it wasn't
just um this sort of
but it wasn't just w h smiths that sold
that you could walk into boots which is
a chemist a pharmacy in the uk quite a
famous one headquartered here in
nottingham and they would be selling
computers i remember going upstairs to
boots in beeston and you'd have a zx
spectrum an acorn electron and so on on
display hooked up to tvs and people
would walk in and type 10 print
hello world
20 go to 10 and often a ruder uh kind of
phrased in hello world but yes not in
the areas i lived in sure i don't know
what happened where you lived it's easy
to forget now that it was this was
delivering a computer
for
a hundred pounds
to someone like me i was i was a 16 year
old
we had a computer at school a
microprocessor system which was a big
thing and it was um but that was
absolutely fantastic because that was a
machine that you could use uh then and
there in front of you and we started
programming that
and it was based on the z80 the in the
zylog z80 chip so having this computer
that you actually had a keyboard and you
could type on and you could program it
that was
a massive step forward and that was like
oh my gosh i can use a computer i've got
a computer in front of me one of the
nice things about
um
there's about all computers at that
point is that they were computing wasn't
just something that you used it was
something that you're going to sort of
program with you were going to hook it
up to automate your house and do things
so they all had some sort of expansion
capability something like the bbc micro
it was dead easy to do things with you
had a user port on the bottom you could
connect that up to some relays and
things with a few transistors and you
could start controlling your model train
set or whatever it is you want to do
which is what i did but you could do the
same on the zx spectrum you have the
edge connector here the edge connector
is basically the processor buses from
the z80 cpu which powers the spectrum so
you've got the address plus you've got
the data burst you've got the i o and
the
memory select signals and if you want to
hook it up to control something you have
to decode all that
yourself now i was five or six at the
time we were doing this i didn't
understand it all but it certainly set
me on the road to understanding how the
hardware worked how you have to decode
the addresses that were coming out of
the cpu so that you knew that this was
actually going to something that you
wanted to control and then you'd have to
feed that into latches or flip-flops so
that you could
control it so why it was much harder to
do something like control a model train
set or
link this into sensors and things and it
will say the bbc micro uh behind me you
actually learned a whole lot more about
how a computer worked by doing it here
the bbc micro is like sort of driving
the
gpios on a raspberry pi you just set an
address in memory and you would turn the
pins on and off and you could control
something most people bought this they
weren't going to do that so why are you
paying for that extra bit you still got
to have a bigger motherboard that's
going to cost more you've got more
fiberglass forming it you've still got
to sort of decode the addresses leave
space for the chips and things if people
aren't going to use that most of the
time why put it on the machine i was
obviously at school and i was working as
a
pot washer in a local restaurant to earn
five pounds a week or something like
this and uh
i was reading the electronic magazines
these computers you start build buying
them and they were still hundreds and
hundreds of pounds 500 pounds 800 pounds
this sort of thing and then suddenly
this sinclair zx80 came out and it was
79.95 or something if you could solder
it yourself and i thought i can't solder
i'm not an electronic engineer and but
99.99 or whatever it was 99.95 at 100
pounds and that was a computer that i
could have in my house
and it's like well that's fantastic
so i bought this thing and i got it home
and i remember the excitement of
unpacking this thing the realization
that it was based on the on the z80 chip
which was the same as the um this school
computer
and so therefore at home i could have
something which used the same chip as
this computer i got in school sinclair
was huge in terms of
getting me interested in coding i really
dilly dallied over whether to do a
physics degree or a computer science
degree sinclair had a massive role to
play in that
computer science no no actually getting
me into coding and of course with the
zx81 i started off with the the 1k
version like everybody did there's not a
lot you can do in 1k unless you get into
assembly language and as a means of
learning assembly it was absolutely
fantastic
i also
um remember
writing some um really simple games like
it was just like a v that you had to
scroll back and forth and there was a
scrolling background with little star
with asterisks as asteroids and you had
to move use the arrow keys to move back
and forth and avoid as much i wrote that
up and i sent it to one of the listings
magazines i can't remember which one but
they accepted it and i published it and
i got a check for i believe 25 quid
which to a 13 year old back in 1981 or
82 was like oh god i'm rich um so yeah
so this is like the magazines used to
have a list of code you copied out you
did and you had to sit there and type it
in and then you'd save it onto your
cassette um
and
then when you graduated from the 1k to
the 16g version and you had your ram
pack at the bottom the back in the the
classic
ram pack wobble issue that you'd be
typing away you'd have got you know 90
lines or 90 pages out of 102 pages and
then suddenly a ram pack wobbles and
it's all gone
so um happy days happy times yes i think
there was something like
2 4 or 8k of
rom
which contained the complete operating
system of the computer and then what
happened was the operating system booted
up and ran
and then the operating system itself
used out of the 1k of memory you ended
up with 760 bytes of memory that you
could actually use
what sinclair was trying to do was
engineer this down to a price because
this came out in 1981 uh and cost around
80 pounds 100 pounds we bought it
assembled
whereas other computers at the time were
costing more like a thousand pounds or
that sort of so that sort of order of
magnitude and different in price so this
really made computers available for the
home user particularly in britain where
there wasn't that much
uh money available and things people
could go and buy one of these they could
start to experiment they could start to
learn how to program and things where
even something like the bbc micro which
came out a couple of years after this
sort of late 82 early 83 was costing
three four hundred pounds this was a
hundred quid you could get one of these
you could play with it and things set it
up but used your tv it used a
standard cassette player as its storage
device
and you could start to experience what
computing was like of course it was
limited down to price every time you
press the key the screen flashes because
it's using the cpu to just drive or
using one aspect of the cpu to drive the
display as well as to process the
instructions to run the program so every
time it's processing instructions it
can't draw things on the display every
time it's drawing things on the display
it can't um
process instructions and so you have to
sort of balance between the two despite
that people managed to produce some
really quite impressive software for the
machine something like 3d monster maze
is a classic example you sort of got
almost a i won't call it a first person
shooter maybe it's a first person maze
game and so on drawing sort of 3d mazes
in the dinosaur it had this built-in
basic language that that could allow you
to program in basic that was fantastic
but i had actually learnt
machine code on the z80 in this school
computer and the sinclair used the same
z80 so it used the same machine code the
school computer had this disassembler
and i worked with the disassembler it
was it had a debugger and a disassembler
so disassembler turns the machine code
numbers you know the the
the raw machine code numbers into a sort
of the text which sort of uh makes it a
sort of human readable form of the
machine code
and i got this running i took the school
stuff and adapted it and worked it and
got it working on the zx80
and then i could disassemble
the entire uh operating system
it was absolutely ingenious it was
absolutely fantastic it sort of
realization again that what it was doing
was it would interrupt the processor
every 50 milliseconds or something and
50 times a second and put a picture onto
the screen and it was sort of so the
processor was writing the
the the image to the screen on a and
this is in the days before
um lcd screens this is this is you know
scanning
televisions and so it had this
interrupting process which interrupted
the operating system and or interrupted
the the program and drew the pictures
onto the screen and so then when it
started running a program it would
disable the interrupts and the screen
would go blank so you had the screen
going blank whilst the program was
running
and then when it stopped running it the
screen would reappear i remember as you
as you read it and understood it
and then that could and then worked out
i worked out how the basic language had
been coded into the system as well so
somewhere in this process
i wrote
the machine code debugger
and uh disassembler for it and sold it
commercially started selling this
commercially unless you've programmed in
machine code realizing
why you need a single step debugger but
you're trying to program
stuff on on a computer like this and so
yeah i i created this machine code
debugger and then we yeah sold it
commercially bringing me income when i
was a student i went by this time i'd
gone to university but in 1981 or
something my machine code debugger was
being sold by a company and so they
wanted me to update it from the zx80 to
the zx81 so i did that and then we got
spectrum and i did the same without
ported it to the spectrum and each time
the machines got a little bit more
sophisticated the zx81 was was obviously
more sophisticated than 80 and the
spectrum was a step up again but they
were still yeah
absolutely ingenious sinclair
in the end was what got me into
computing i mean uh he was a visionary i
think he's probably a good one he's a
visionary he was an inventor
he had i mean the electric bike is a
classic example there electric scooters
are everywhere now
sinclair tried to produce on with the c5
he had the zeit i think it was called a
few years later he introduced a portable
computer the z88 was a lovely machine
that he produced which was sort of like
a i think was a six or seven line eighty
column lcd display with a keyboard
in a machine about the size of a piece
of a4 paper and probably not much
thicker than that which you could throw
in a bag that had a rubber keyboard so
it was
resilient and things and you had a
portable machine that you could hook up
and sort of take around the battery life
was ages it came with the word processor
it actually came with bbc basic on there
had a richard russell's version of bbc
basic for the z80 on there and he was
definitely a visionary i think perhaps
my only disappointment is that the only
time i saw a sinclair c5 i wasn't able
to go in because my legs weren't long
enough at that age to pedal it and then
the fact that i wrote this
debugger and so on and sold it through
university was then supplementing my
student income through university so in
many ways the sinclair zx 8081 and
spectrum got me through university in
more ways than one i ended up paying for
my beer money as well as sparking my
interest in computing i'm a very keen
advocate for as much coding as possible
in physics courses i would almost say
that
well i would definitely say that coding
is as important as mathematics and
physics courses i'm almost of the
opinion now that coding is even more
important than mathematics and physics
courses and
yeah so it's been with me since a very
very early age
i when i
think about a physics problem and
certainly during my undergraduate years
during my phd and even now it says can i
code this and if or see a way to code it
and if i can't code it or see a way to
code it i know i don't understand it if
i can't think of the algorithm then i
don't understand that particular piece
of physics
and
you know that all goes all the way back
to the zx81 sitting in that room with
the ram pack wobbling all over the place
and uh typing in that stuff and it's it
was character building let's put it that
way sean i must have been about seven or
eight and the first computer i ever laid
eyes on knowingly or that i knew was a
computer was a sinclair zx81
um
we were playing out in the street some
friends some neighbors and somebody said
that one of our neighbors had this
computer and we all we're all allowed to
come in and look at it so we all kind of
filed into this room and
i don't know to this day what he was
doing on the computer probably loading a
game or something because it didn't seem
like much happened we hadn't seen
anything like it before i mean outside
of the arcades you
in your home atari was about as far as
it went we've done videos on the atari
vcs to 2600 it was kind of like that but
you could write different games yourself
you would get these magazines and
there'd be a
list of code and you'd type that code in
as faithfully as you could and if you
weren't faithful enough it didn't work
so you had to be pretty faithful
and then you might tweak it and you go
oh actually it says there enter press
any keys i'm going to type something
different there let's see what happens
so i know i remember yeah a lot of fond
memories of messing around with these
things it's been a while since i've
played this
a good amount of beer money shall we say
i mean you know we're talking in through
my university career i mean this is say
1980 to well i was at university 81 to
84. i was probably making
hundreds of pounds a term
they say hundreds of pounds a term so
over the course of the university maybe
a few thousand pounds you know
this didn't make me a billionaire this
didn't make me a steve jobs but it paid
for me
this was a time when my dad became
unemployed and i
my mum and dad couldn't give me any
money and i was having to pay for my own
way through university and it was
it was the money from the sinclair zx80
and 81 and
spectrum that uh
basically paid my way for me through
university so
in many ways i've got a lot to i owe to
the
clive sinclair
[Music]
[Laughter]
you